olá, meu nome é Olivia Lan e sou pesquisadora e educadora no IBM Quantum. Este vídeo marca o lançamento de uma
nova série no canal do YouTube do Qiskit e na nossa plataforma de aprendizado, chamada Computação Quântica na
Prática. Em resumo, nesta série vou te mostrar como usar um computador quântico que existe agora, aproveitando todo o seu
potencial. Já existem bilhões de vídeos na internet sobre computadores quânticos e seu potencial futuro, ou sobre conceitos teóricos
por trás da computação quântica, que também são igualmente importantes. Veja, por exemplo, "Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica",
apresentado por John Watrous. Mas neste curso vamos partir do princípio de que o estudante já sabe um pouco mais
do que no passado, e vamos avançar bastante tecnicamente. E isso se deve ao fato de que, no último ano — e no
momento desta gravação estamos em 2024 — presenciamos uma mudança, uma transição de fase, por assim dizer, para uma nova era da
computação. Os computadores quânticos estão finalmente se aproximando do ponto em que podem ser úteis. Embora experimentar com
circuits de pequena escala e computadores quânticos tenha sido necessário para educar nossa comunidade sobre como usar essas máquinas, ninguém estava executando experimentos
que não pudessem ser realizados em computadores clássicos comuns. Mas a partir de hoje entramos em uma era de
utilidade quântica. E o que é utilidade, você pode perguntar? É diferente da Vantagem Quântica, que pode ser entendida como o
ponto em que os computadores quânticos superam os clássicos em uma tarefa significativa. Em vez disso, utilidade significa
que eles podem começar a competir entre si, e este é o próximo passo natural na evolução
tecnológica. A IBM publicou um artigo que mostrou, pela primeira vez no ano passado, que um computador quântico poderia ser usado para
simular um modelo físico e competir com técnicas de simulação clássica de ponta. Ele até superou as
tentativas de força bruta e abriu para os pesquisadores uma nova avenida que podem usar em suas pesquisas. Então por que tudo isso está acontecendo
agora? Bem, nos últimos meses a IBM disponibilizou amplamente processadores quânticos com mais de 100 qubits. Se você já
é um usuário, deve ter percebido que removemos muitos dos nossos processadores menores para dar lugar a esses chips maiores, e sentimos que era realmente
importante fazer isso, pois alguns números de qubits ainda podem ser simulados classicamente sem problemas. Portanto,
não há vantagem real em usar esses chips. Porém, com 100 qubits isso não é mais o caso: eles não podem
ser simulados classicamente. Também é importante notar que existem o que chamamos de simuladores,
que são essencialmente programas de computador e podem imitar alguns comportamentos de sistemas quânticos, incluindo ruído. Porém,
não deixe passar o fato de que eu disse "imitar". Simuladores não são computadores quânticos. Eles não conseguem produzir os resultados que
os computadores quânticos conseguem nessa escala, mas ainda são uma parte importante do nosso fluxo de testes. Então essa foi uma resposta bem
longa à pergunta no topo deste slide: o que é Computação Quântica Prática? Neste curso, vou te ensinar sobre casos de uso
com potencial real para o Quântico e as melhores práticas para executar e experimentar nesses processadores de maior escala
atualmente. Então, para quem é este curso? Vamos começar fazendo um nivelamento
inicial. Este curso é para todos que desejam desenvolver novos aplicativos para computadores quânticos, que querem
saber como escalar seu trabalho atual, ou aprender a usar o quântico em seus fluxos de trabalho existentes. Mencionei
anteriormente que este curso será muito prático e não discutiremos aspectos teóricos tanto. Esperamos
que você venha com uma compreensão básica do que é a computação quântica, mas se ainda não chegou lá, não se preocupe, assista
os primeiros episódios do curso de John Watrous e você estará pronto. Também queremos garantir que as pessoas que estão assistindo saibam
que este não é apenas um curso para físicos ou cientistas da computação. Essas duas áreas têm
monopolizado a Computação Quântica na última década ou mais. Queremos garantir que outros que trabalham com big data ou
simulações, como engenheiros, químicos e cientistas de materiais, saibam que este curso também é para eles. Em resumo, este
curso é direcionado a um público amplo e esperamos que você nos acompanhe em sua totalidade. Ao concluir este curso, você
será capaz de entender como criar e executar um job em escala de utilidade através do Qiskit Runtime, incluindo todo o fluxo de trabalho.
Você também será capaz de entender os principais tipos de mitigação de erros e compreender as prováveis áreas de aplicação no curto prazo. Você também será capaz de
executar todos esses algoritmos no Qiskit e, por último, esperamos que você seja capaz de entender o ruído e como lidar com ele.
Então vamos começar. A Computação Quântica é uma tecnologia nova e empolgante em um estágio inicial de desenvolvimento, mas é apenas
um capítulo na história da computação, que remonta a milhares de anos. Acho importante entender esse
contexto porque torna o que estamos tentando fazer aqui um pouco mais intuitivo, previsível e menos
ficção científica. Desde a antiguidade, nós, humanos, precisamos realizar computações ou,
em outras palavras, processar informações de acordo com certas regras e restrições para viabilizar
comunicação, construção, comércio, ciência e todos os outros aspectos de nossas vidas. Buscamos no mundo físico
assistência e, através de descobertas geniais, construímos dispositivos para nos ajudar a computar. Há muito tempo, dispositivos eram
feitos de madeira, osso, cordas com nós, e armazenavam informações e facilitavam cálculos de forma muito diferente do que fazemos
hoje. Dispositivos mecânicos construídos com alavancas, engrenagens e outras máquinas avançaram desde os primeiros relógios astronômicos até
calculadoras e sofisticados dispositivos de computação, como analisadores diferenciais que resolviam equações usando rodas e
discos giratórios. Até a tecnologia da escrita desempenhou um papel importante na história, permitindo que as pessoas realizassem
computações que não seriam capazes de realizar de outra forma. Quando pensamos em computadores hoje, tendemos a pensar em
computadores digitais eletrônicos, mas essa é na verdade uma tecnologia bastante recente. Os computadores digitais eletrônicos
foram construídos pela primeira vez na década de 1940. A ferramenta mais antiga conhecida para computação é, na verdade, o ábaco sumeriano,
que os especialistas acreditam ter sido inventado na Babilônia por volta de 2700 a 2300 a.C. Isso é há muito
tempo. Mas fomos compreendendo cada vez mais o mundo natural — de Arquimedes a Euclid, a
Einstein — e nossa necessidade de mais recursos computacionais explodiu. Hoje temos supercomputadores, que são
basicamente muitos computadores muito poderosos conectados em paralelo. Eles são uma das melhores ferramentas que a humanidade tem para
resolver problemas difíceis, mas ainda há muitos problemas que até esses gigantes dos computadores jamais serão capazes de
resolver. Mais sobre isso depois. Então estabelecemos que os humanos têm usado a física e a natureza para nos ajudar a computar
por milhares de anos, e para nos ajudar em nossa busca interminável por computar mais e coisas maiores. Você talvez já
conheça a Lei de Moore. Na verdade, não é bem uma lei, é uma observação — o nome "lei" é um pouco
irônico, na minha opinião. O número máximo de transistores em um circuito integrado, basicamente um chip de computador,
dobra a cada 2 anos aproximadamente. Nas últimas 5 décadas ou mais, não só observamos isso, como fizemos grande uso
disso. Com mais transistores, podemos realizar mais computações e mais rápidas. Isso é essencialmente o que é responsável por
tornar os computadores cada vez mais poderosos e menores ao longo do tempo. Porém, há uma má notícia: a Lei de Moore está morrendo.
Os especialistas discordam sobre quando a Lei de Moore chegará ao seu fim inevitável, mas alguns dizem que já chegou. Embora possamos não
saber exatamente quando atingiremos nosso limite, sabemos que isso é inevitável, porque algumas partes dos transistores
não podem ser fisicamente menores. Não se pode fazer um transistor menor do que um átomo, por exemplo. Isso
é completamente não físico — parece bobo, mas são os limites com que estamos trabalhando. Então o que
vamos fazer? Simplesmente desistir e dizer que é o melhor que dá? Não. Os humanos nunca fizeram isso. Felizmente, a mecânica
quântica entrou em cena. A mecânica quântica foi descoberta na década de 1920, e desde então o mundo
literalmente nunca foi o mesmo. Poderíamos passar horas falando sobre as descobertas revolucionárias que foram
feitas, mas esse não é o foco deste curso. Em vez disso, quero deixar claro que sabemos que a mecânica
quântica e a computação já são compatíveis entre si. As descobertas e compreensões da natureza
que aprendemos com a mecânica quântica tornaram possíveis, em parte, os nossos computadores modernos. Sem a mecânica
quântica, não entenderíamos e provavelmente nem teríamos sido capazes de inventar o disco rígido de estado sólido,
por exemplo. A computação quântica é simplesmente o próximo passo natural nessa evolução.
Mas a computação não existe no vácuo. A informação requer um meio.
Computar informação aproveita o mundo físico e o afeta também. Isso impõe limitações ao que é
fisicamente possível, mas entender a natureza e as limitações físicas é justamente o objetivo da física como
disciplina. Então, de certa forma, física e computação sempre estiveram entrelaçadas. Ralph Landauer, cientista da computação e pesquisador da
IBM, reconheceu décadas atrás que a informação é física. Em outras palavras, a informação não é uma
entidade abstrata, mas existe apenas por meio de representação física. O princípio de Landauer estabelece uma conexão
entre a informação e as leis da termodinâmica. Mas de fato há muitas conexões entre física e
computação. A física clássica era tudo o que conseguíamos explorar até recentemente, mas com a descoberta da mecânica
quântica, estamos agora à beira de conseguir criar uma forma completamente nova de computar. E isso é ótimo porque
os computadores clássicos só conseguem aproximar o que realmente ocorre na natureza e, em alguns casos, essa aproximação é muito
limitada. Isso porque é muito, muito difícil fazer máquinas que seguem as leis da física clássica para
aproximar as leis da física quântica. E a natureza não é clássica, é quântica. Uma analogia que pode ajudar a
entender é o túnel de vento. A dinâmica dos fluidos é notoriamente difícil de simular e prever matematicamente.
Até algo tão mundano quanto um carro andando num vento — os fabricantes de carros descobriram que era, na verdade,
muito caro e impraticável tentar simular essa interação física ao projetar carros. Em vez disso, o que
acabaram fazendo foi criar um túnel literal que sopra vento, e simplesmente colocar o carro no túnel
e ver como ele se comporta. Isso é análogo ao que quero dizer quando digo que os computadores clássicos aproximam mal
a natureza e às vezes é muito caro até tentar fazê-los fazer isso. Em vez de simular o vento,
os pesquisadores simplesmente o recriam. Da mesma forma, os computadores quânticos não precisam aproximar as leis da natureza em nível
molecular, porque seguem essas leis intrinsecamente. Eles não precisam simular nada — eles emulam. E
as mesmas dificuldades surgem quando estamos simulando baterias ou reações químicas, o que nos leva à nossa próxima
seção: Computação Quântica — para que serve?
Por que queremos combinar mecânica quântica e computação? Bem, já há muitos
problemas que são difíceis demais, computacionalmente custosos demais até para nossos supercomputadores de ponta resolverem.
Talvez esses sejam problemas nos quais apenas pesquisadores estejam muito focados, mas seus impactos podem alcançar todas as partes do
globo. Esses problemas em que os computadores clássicos travam são coisas com as quais nós, como sociedade, estamos nos tornando cada vez mais
dependentes da tecnologia e nos importamos muito: como a eficiência de baterias, modelagem financeira e
otimização, e até como construir aviões melhores. Então por que recorrer a computadores quânticos? Temos boas razões
para acreditar que há muito potencial aqui, e podemos abrir portas para novas computações que atualmente estão fora do alcance até dos
supercomputadores mais poderosos. Em teoria, alguns algoritmos quânticos fornecem vantagens sobre os
melhores algoritmos clássicos possíveis para algumas aplicações. Para outras aplicações, há evidências crescentes de que, mesmo
com algum ruído e imperfeições, os computadores quânticos ainda podem ser usados como ferramenta para competir com soluções clássicas de força
bruta. Basicamente, é uma ferramenta totalmente nova e queremos descobrir coisas ainda mais legais que podemos fazer com ela. Mas podemos
também recorrer à ideia original de Feynman para eles, que é usá-los para entender a física e a natureza em si.
Afinal, já disse que a natureza é quântica, não clássica, e esse campo é incrivelmente rico, fascinante e
interdisciplinar. Ele reúne física, ciência da computação, processamento de informação e, claro, os domínios específicos das áreas de aplicação que
podem nos interessar. No entanto, ao contrário dos computadores clássicos, nem todo mundo tem um computador quântico no
bolso. Até muito recentemente, se você quisesse experimentar com um computador quântico, precisava construir e manter
um por conta própria, geralmente em um laboratório deprimente no porão de uma universidade ou centro de pesquisa. E confie em mim, eu sei bem disso. Mas isso
não é mais o caso. Em 2016, a IBM colocou o primeiro processador quântico na nuvem. Tinha apenas cinco qubits na época e
taxas de erros bastante altas, mas isso foi apenas 8 anos atrás, e olha como avançamos. Então onde estamos hoje?
Há muitos paralelos a serem traçados com os primórdios do computador moderno. Como mencionei, este é um desafio
muito difícil e foi apenas nos últimos 8 anos que os computadores quânticos se tornaram amplamente disponíveis, exceto para
aqueles que trabalham em laboratórios ou instalações de ponta. Mas nesses últimos oito anos fizemos progresso em todas as
frentes: os processadores são ordens de magnitude maiores em número de qubits, os gates melhoraram muito e introduzimos métodos
para reduzir ou mitigar erros intrínsecos aos sistemas quânticos, mesmo enquanto avançamos para criar
computadores quânticos tolerantes a falhas. Agora você e qualquer outra pessoa pode usar um desses numerosos processadores IBM Quantum
hospedados na nuvem, quase todos sendo os sistemas mais novos e avançados, com mais de 100
qubits. Mas não é apenas o tamanho dos processadores que importa. Essa é apenas uma métrica que nos interessa, e
faz sentido, certo? Se temos mais qubits, isso é obviamente melhor, desde que aumentar o número de qubits
não degrade o desempenho. Porém, isso nem sempre é o caso. Precisamos de mais qubits de boa qualidade que não interfiram
uns com os outros através de crosstalk quando não queremos que o façam. A forma como os qubits estão conectados entre si também é importante de se ter em mente. Em
circuits supercondutores, é um desafio descobrir como conectar fisicamente os qubits da melhor forma. Outra métrica de enorme importância
é a fidelidade do gate de dois qubits. Os gates que operam em qubits individuais não são tão propensos a erros. Os gates de dois qubits são a área de
maior preocupação e geralmente uma das métricas principais que observamos para ver como o desempenho está melhorando ao
longo do tempo. Os gates de dois qubits são cruciais de se acertar porque são responsáveis por criar entrelaçamento entre os qubits,
que é um dos fenômenos físicos que dá aos computadores quânticos seu poder. Por último, buscamos velocidade e eficiência:
precisamos garantir que o tempo gasto executando um programa no chip quântico seja executado de forma mais rápida e eficiente
possível. Nos referimos a essas três métricas juntas como escala, qualidade e
velocidade. Todas elas são vitais para melhorar o desempenho. Agora quero mostrar alguns gráficos rápidos para embasar o que tenho
dito sobre como a tecnologia em si está evoluindo bastante rapidamente. A contagem de qubits em si é a mais fácil de
entender, eu acho, e a IBM publicou um roadmap de onde esperamos estar nos próximos anos em termos de contagem de qubits
e tamanho dos processadores. Para 2024, quando estamos gravando este vídeo, estamos bem dentro do prazo com nossos processadores Heron e Condor. A seguir,
qualidade: este gráfico mostra a taxa mediana de erros de gate de entrelaçamento nos processadores IBM Quantum ao longo do tempo. Lembre-se
de que esta é uma escala logarítmica, então, embora o progresso pareça vagamente linear, é na verdade muito mais rápido do que isso.
Por último, temos velocidade: este gráfico mostra o progresso de uma métrica que chamamos de CLOPS, que significa circuit layer
operations per second. Crucialmente, CLOPS encapsula tanto o tempo que leva para executar circuits quanto a computação clássica real e de
tempo próximo necessária. Basicamente, CLOPS é uma medida de quão rapidamente nossos processadores podem executar circuits específicos em
série, atuando como uma medida de velocidade holística do sistema e incorporando computação quântica e clássica.
Neste momento, no momento da gravação, a IBM é a única provedora de nuvem quântica que fornece acesso a máquinas com 100
qubits ou mais. Como mencionei alguns slides atrás, 100 qubits, ou algo próximo disso, é onde a simulação clássica
começa a falhar completamente. Portanto, jobs de grande escala executados nessas máquinas muitas vezes não têm equivalente clássico — simplesmente não é
possível. Há alguma nuance e algumas dicas e truques que você pode usar para simular algumas partes de um circuit e depois outras
partes separadamente, mas em geral sabemos que é por volta desse número que os computadores quânticos podem começar a fazer coisas que os computadores clássicos simplesmente não conseguem. Então
a IBM decidiu que dar acesso a esses dispositivos maiores era muito importante para a comunidade em geral, porque qualquer coisa
feita em dispositivos menores é simulável classicamente e, portanto, não pode levar à Vantagem Quântica. Os dispositivos de 100 qubits
que temos agora ainda são imperfeitos e ainda são ruidosos, então precisamos ser inteligentes sobre como executamos jobs e
circuits neles. Simplesmente escrever nosso circuit e pressionar Shift+Enter provavelmente não vai levar a nada
espetacular. Mas, novamente, há dicas e truques que podemos implementar e melhores práticas que podemos seguir para extrair ainda
mais desempenho desses dispositivos, o que esperamos levar à Vantagem Quântica mais cedo, mesmo enquanto continuamos
trabalhando e construindo nossas máquinas tolerantes a falhas também. Este gráfico mostra o custo da simulação,
ou o tempo que leva para resolver um problema em computadores clássicos e em computadores quânticos equipados com mitigação de erros
e correção de erros. Então a linha de computação clássica escala exponencialmente à medida que a complexidade do circuit
cresce. Para circuits simples aqui embaixo isso não importa, mas é obviamente ruim à medida que a complexidade cresce, porque isso
torna o custo da simulação muito caro muito rapidamente. A mitigação de erros escala melhor, então quando a complexidade do
circuit cresce, é aqui que queremos estar. Atualmente estamos aqui, com métodos clássicos e quânticos mais ou menos
equiparados para algumas aplicações, e a correção de erros pode ser a mais preferível e escala muito
bem — só que ainda não chegamos lá. Enquanto isso, continuaremos focando na mitigação de erros e chegar a esta
área de utilidade quântica o mais rápido possível, e fazendo uso de vários esquemas de mitigação de erros, que
aprenderemos nesta série. Nosso objetivo é encontrar áreas de aplicação que possam fazer uso da utilidade quântica muito em breve. E é isso
que está no coração deste curso. Temos essas máquinas, acreditamos que elas são capazes de fazer algumas pesquisas muito interessantes.
Então como as usamos? Nesta última seção do episódio, vamos discutir brevemente as áreas de aplicação para a
Computação Quântica prática. Existem três ramos principais que achamos que estamos mais animados para explorar e encontrar caminhos para a utilidade
quântica. O primeiro é simular a natureza. Isso tem a ver com a simulação de interações moleculares ou atômicas, e é
muito importante para áreas de ciência de materiais e química. Pelas razões que discutimos anteriormente, acreditamos que os computadores
quânticos serão muito melhores nisso do que seus equivalentes clássicos. Em seguida, há busca e
otimização. O principal algoritmo de interesse aqui é chamado QAOA, um algoritmo quântico-clássico híbrido. O QAOA usa um
computador clássico para treinar e encontrar parâmetros ótimos para um quantum circuit, e esperamos conseguir fazer isso
muito mais eficientemente do que qualquer computador poderia fazer sozinho. Por último, temos matemática e processamento de dados com estrutura. Os computadores
quânticos são muito bons em encontrar estruturas em dados confusos onde você, eu ou um computador típico poderia não ver
nada. O aprendizado de máquina quântico é promissor nessa área e pretendemos usar isso para tarefas como extração de
características e reconhecimento de padrões. É realmente um momento muito empolgante para quem trabalha no
campo da computação quântica. Pela primeira vez na história, podemos começar a explorar uma região da computação que vai além da
computação clássica. Quem está assistindo a isso pode ter um papel semelhante ao dos primeiros pioneiros da
computação, e eles não tinham ideia do que viria depois. T.J. Watson, da IBM, chegou a dizer famosamente que achava que haveria
mercado para apenas dois ou três computadores no total, e ele errou muito. Nós
somos todos aqueles primeiros pioneiros da computação, mas neste novo campo da computação quântica. E o quântico é frequentemente
contrastado com a computação clássica como algo distintamente diferente dela e muitas vezes em competição com ela. Mas meu
objetivo nesta aula introdutória era te convencer de que, a partir de uma visão panorâmica, podemos enxergar a
Computação Quântica simplesmente como o próximo capítulo em uma longa história da computação. É da nossa natureza como humanos buscar novas formas de
computar e aproveitar o poder do mundo natural para descobrir o que fazer com ele, e temos feito isso por
séculos. A Computação Quântica nos oferece uma nova ferramenta nessa jornada, e cabe a nós descobrir como podemos aproveitar
o poder que ela nos oferece. Na próxima lição da série, falaremos um pouco mais sobre os sistemas de 100 qubits
e daremos uma visão geral do Qiskit, nosso SDK de software quântico, e de como interagir melhor com essas máquinas agora. Obrigada por
assistir e até a próxima.